- And you start buying
drinks for everybody
as soon as she comes over,
I mean, who does that?
- Meegan, come back to the bar!
- You're literally an asshole!
- How's that possible?
I can't be an asshole, I got
arms and legs and a head!
(theme music)
- All right, everybody focus up, look.
This party tonight could be a model
for the way that the world should work.
And I just wanna say,
I'm totally stoked to the
max about it, all right?
You guys feeling good?
- Yeah.
- Hell yeah, good.
- Dennis, what are you shooting video?
- [Dennis] Yeah, man.
- All right, well, be careful with that.
I might run for office someday.
(crowd laughing)
Now, trust me, I think
that this party can be
the most inspirational party
this campus has ever seen.
Is that coming to me?
Let me just grab that.
Some righteous bud,
some righteous bud we got going on there.
We need some bodacious
jock babes coming in.
- [Guy] Yeah.
- We need some hot ass punk rock babes.
- Yeah.
- Woo.
- I don't care where they come from.
The most important thing,
it's imperative that we have a diversity
in the pussy department.
Intercepted, don't sleep on Barry O.
Don't ever sleep on Barry O.
Ooh!
(people chattering)
- Hey.
- Apartheid is totally gnarly.
It's a gnarly institution.
Where is he, Dennis,
Dennis, come over here.
Get this, get this.
Okay, we gotta have a system in place
to get everybody weed, all right?
So just watch this, this
is how you're gonna do it,
all right, this, this is,
I'm really (bleep) frosty
right now, by the way.
This is your constitution, all right?
It's just a piece of paper.
We gotta keep its integrity,
'cause it's gonna hold
everything together.
This right here, this is us.
This is the American people.
We're special, we're magic.
Hello, yay, y'all live in here.
All right, the most important thing
is that we don't get too far apart.
Me and you, we gotta be close.
That's that's the magic
of America, is love.
Otherwise, we're gonna
get air bubbles in there.
It's gonna start canoeing and everything.
We don't want that.
All right, you get that?
All right look, I'm way ahead
of you, but I'm already done.
Boom fireworks, 4th of July.
That's for you.
We want like 10 of these.
Oh my God, I'm so (bleep) blazed.
I'm so (bleep) high.
Oh (bleep) what was I saying?
- All I know is its good
having another brother
move into the neighborhood.
- Hey, man, it's good to have you over.
And I think that you will dig this.
- All right.
Hey!
- Huh?
- Nice guitar collection.
- Oh, thanks, man.
Hey, you wanna hear something?
- Yeah, sure.
- All right, all right.
All right, let's get this
started, let's get this started.
(acoustic guitar music)
♪ Well, I'm just a good old American boy ♪
♪ With a heart that's
red, white, and true ♪
♪ I'm dreamin' of the girl with
the red hair and freckles ♪
♪ And her eyes like the skies of blue ♪
- Country music.
- Yeah, I grew up in
Texas, you know, so...
- All right.
♪ Keep her safe from the homies
in the wrong side of town ♪
♪ Where they're smokin' the
reefer and acting like clowns ♪
♪ Keep that pretty white dress
from getting dirty and brown ♪
♪ 'Cause that's the American way ♪
woo-hoo!
- Whoa.
Pretty racist song. (laughs)
- Racist? Against who?
- Black people.
- Black people?
But I'm black. (laughs)
- Well, keeping the redheaded girl
away from the homies on
the wrong side of town?
- Homies?
Come on, brother, there's
all kinds of homies.
You know, white homies, asian homies.
- No, homies are black.
- No, I think you're
making them black, man.
I think that's your stuff.
You hear the twang and then
you assume that it's racist.
But that's just what
country music is like.
Here, look, you're gonna like this one.
You'll like this one.
- All right.
(acoustic guitar music)
♪ Some folks wear their
hats way off to the side ♪
♪ With their pants down low
and a gun tucked inside ♪
♪ Take their beer by the 40
and their chicken deep-fried ♪
♪ I think we all know
who we're talking about ♪
♪ The only dark I like is
when I turn off the lights ♪
♪ The only hood I love
is pointy and white ♪
♪ Can't trust you if I can't
see your face at night ♪
♪ I think we all know
who we're talking about ♪
- All right, wait, hey!
Stop that.
That's racist.
- What's, what?
What is racist about it?
- "The only hood I love
is pointy and white"?
- Yeah, man.
- That's talking about the Klan, man.
- The Ku Klux Klan?
Are you outside of your mind?
That's traditional country
music imagery, man,
like a pickup truck or
sleeping under the stars,
or your dog got killed or your
wife left you, same thing!
- I would have been fine
with any of those things.
- What is the difference
between those things
and what is in the song?
- They're not racial!
- Hey, you know what, can
I just say something, man?
I'm just gonna be frank.
You're getting a little,
like, Al Sharpton,
like, Farrakhan on me right now.
- Oh, my god.
Are you serious?
- Yo, dude, dude, please,
hey, can I do one more?
Let me just do one more, dog.
I absolutely promise you
that this song is not racist
and it's impossible for you
to misinterpret it as such.
- Okay, it seems like you're about to sing
the most racist song so far.
- I'm not.
♪ hidey-lidey-lidey-lee ♪
♪ Get me a rope and find me a tree ♪
- Okay, I'm out.
- Come on, man. hey!
Shoot.
I'm over here trying to
sing about a tire swing.
Gonna write off an entire genre of music.
♪ The banjos are strumming,
and the drums are a-bangin' ♪
♪ Let's get the boys together
and have ourselves a-hangin' ♪
oh, damn.
Now I see it.
(school bell ringing)
- All right, listen up, y'all.
I'm y'all's substitute
teacher, Mr. Garvey.
I taught school for 20
years in the inner city,
so don't even think about messing with me.
Y'all feel me?
- Mm-hmm.
- Okay.
Let's take roll here.
Jay Quellin.
Where's Jay Quellin at?
No Jay Quellin here?
Yeah.
- Uh, do you mean "Jacqueline"?
- Okay.
So that's how it's gonna be.
Y'all wanna play.
Okay, then.
I got my eyes on you, Jay Quellin.
Balakay.
Where is Balakay at?
There's no Balakay here today?
Yes, sir.
- My name is Blake.
- Bl...
Are you out of your goddamn mind?
"Blake"!
What?
Do you wanna go to war, Balakey?
- No.
- 'Cause we could go to war.
- I'm for real.
I'm for real.
So you better check yourself.
Dee-nice.
Is there a Dee-Nice?
If one of y'all says some silly-ass name,
this whole class is gonna feel my wrath.
Now, Dee-Nice.
- Do you mean "Denise"?
- Son of a bitch!
You say your name right, right now.
- Denise?
- You say it right.
- Denise.
- Correctly.
- Right.
- Denise.
- Dee-Nice?
- That's better, thank you.
Now, A.A. Ron.
Where are you?
Where is A.A. Ron right now?
No A. A. Ron, huh?
Well, you better be sick,
dead or mute, A.A. Ron.
- Here! Oh, man.
- Why didn't you answer me
the first time I said it, huh?
- Huh?
- You know, I'm just asking you.
I said it, like, four times.
So, why didn't you say it the
first time I said, "A.A. Ron"?
- Because it's pronounced "Aaron".
- Son of a bitch!
You done messed up, A.A. Ron!
Now take your ass on down
to Oh-Shag-Henessy's office,
right now, and tell him
exactly what you did!
- Who?
- Oh-Shag-Henessy!
- Principal O'Shaughnessy?
- Get out of my goddamn classroom
before I break my foot off in your ass!
Insubordinate
and churlish.
Tym-Oh-Thee.
- Present.
- Thank you.
(door knocking)
- Here we go, we got more.
Hey!
- Hey!
- What's up, Ted and Annette?
Come on in.
Yes.
- All right.
- Fangs for coming. (laughs)
Have a bloody good time.
Awesome.
Oh, oh.
- Hee-hee.
- There he is.
What's up, Noah?
- Hee-hee.
- Michael Jackson.
- Hoo!
Hee-hee.
- That's what he does.
- Hee-hee.
- That's Michael Jackson.
- Great. |
- Hee.
Hee.
Ow!
- Nice.
- Ooh! Shumm.
- Oh, there we go.
- Shumm.
- There we go.
- All right, three is the charm.
- Shamone.
- Four, all right well-
- Annie, are you okay?
- Oh, he's leaning.
He's leaning.
- Are you okay, Annie?
- Are you okay?
- Annie, are you okay, Annie?
You've been touched by a smooth criminal.
- Very nice. Oh.
- Shamone.
- More kicks.
- Closer. Closer.
- Four kicks.
- Close to your face.
- You almost hit me there.
You're really getting-
- Shamone!
- No more shamone.
You wanna come inside?
That's annoying, that is very annoying.
Stop. Stop!
Don't do it anymore.
Great.
- Shamone.
- You keep doing the shamone.
- Where the children at, hee-hee.
- Where are the children at?
That's in bad taste.
This isn't...
Don't even know what that is.
- Thriller eyes.
Shamone.
- What are you doing?
- Jam it. Jam it on.
- No, you're cut off of shamone.
- Oh, okay.
Ha!
- He doesn't slap his ass like that,
so I don't know what, okay.
- Nanana, nanana, nananana.
Nanana.
- No, he doesn't,
I've never seen him hit his ass.
- Oh!
- Hey.
Can we just...
Hey, stop, stop.
Stop, stop it!
Stop it!
The (bleep) costume's awful.
The impression is stupid and played out.
Everybody and their
mother was Michael Jackson
three years ago when he died.
- He died?
- Oh.
- Wait, wait, wait, he died?
- Oh, Noah.
Oh, Noah.
- Boo-hoo.
- Now, wait, wait a second.
Don't sad moonwalk away.
- Boo-hoo.
- [Host] Happy Halloween.
("Non-Stop Party" by LMFAO)
♪ Well, tonight we gonna party
'til the party don't stop ♪
♪ And the party don't stop
because it keeps on going ♪
♪ Non-stop, gonna party all night ♪
♪ Gonna keep this party going ♪
♪ 'Cause the party won't stop ♪
♪ It's been two straight days
and the party's still going ♪
♪ 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7 days ♪
♪ 'Til it's Friday again
and the party keeps going ♪
♪ Party all night 'cause
it's an all-night party ♪
♪ Friday night, 9 PM ♪
♪ Hop in the car, call my friends ♪
♪ Drinks in the back, girls out front ♪
♪ Going to a party, sending texts ♪
♪ Cell phone rings, iPad, Facebook ♪
♪ Party time, skin-tight jeans ♪
♪ Friday night, dance dance dance ♪
♪ 'Cause tonight we going out
and we ain't coming back ♪
♪ 'Cause the party won't
stop, it will go all night ♪
♪ Friday night, every night ♪
♪ The party's going down ♪
♪ Down, down, down, down,
down, down, down, down, down ♪
♪ New York City, LA, Chicago ♪
♪ Houston, Philly, San Diego ♪
♪ Phoenix, Boston, Fort Worth, Austin ♪
♪ Memphis, Denver, Portland, Vegas ♪
♪ Tucson, Fresno, Akron, Tampa ♪
♪ Pittsburgh, Newark, Plano, Lincoln ♪
♪ Lubbock, Durham, Salem, Dayton ♪
♪ City, city, city, city ♪
♪ 'Cause tonight we going out
and we ain't coming back ♪
♪ 'Cause the party won't
stop, it will go all night ♪
♪ Friday night, every night ♪
♪ The party's going down ♪
♪ Down, down, down, down,
down, down, down, down, down ♪
♪ New York City, LA, Chicago ♪
♪ Houston, Philly, San Diego ♪
♪ Phoenix, Boston, Fort Worth, Austin ♪
♪ Memphis, Denver, Portland, Vegas ♪
♪ Tucson, Fresno, Akron, Tampa ♪
♪ Pittsburgh, Newark, Plano, Lincoln ♪
♪ Lubbock, Durham, Salem, Dayton ♪
♪ City, city, city, city, cities ♪
♪ Now we're gonna keep it
going to the break of dawn ♪
♪ Then we'll just keep
partying all day long ♪
♪ Hot girls, music, dancing
and bikinis and headphones ♪
♪ Party, party, party, party,
party, party, party, party ♪
(guns banging)
♪ So tonight we gonna party
'til the party don't stop ♪
- In what universe is the "Family Circus"
better than "Dilbert"?
For instance, oh, yo, what's up, man?
How you,
(dramatic music)
been?
- Oh, you know, cuz.
keepin' it straight.
(dramatic music)
You know.
- All right, cool.
Well, I guess I'll check you later.
- All right, dog.
What you should have seen was rain people,
with James Caan and Shirley Knight.
- Yo.
- Uh, what's up, man?
(dramatic music)
- You got something to say?
- Yeah, man, um...
How's Denise?
- Oh, yeah, Denise.
She good, she good, she good.
Anyway, guess I'll catch you on the flip.
- Yeah, dog, yeah. ain't no thing.
- Come on, stick it.
- I'm in there, dog.
- Come on.
- No, I'm in there, dog, I'm in there.
- Tuck it.
- I'm in there.
- I'm tuckin' it in, brother.
I'm in there, dog, I'm in
there, dog, I'm in there, dog.
- You know, all right.
(dramatic music)
(sewing machine humming)
- Oh.
Huh, anyway, you know,
you gotta come real,
come correct, when you coming
at all, you know? (laughs)
That's basically how I roll.
(sewing machine humming)
- Are you kidding me?
- No!
- Seriously, you've gotta come
back in the bar right now.
- You come back in the bar!
- Megan, I don't even (bleep) know claire!
- Yeah, right!
- I'm sorry!
You left your jacket!
- Yeah, well, why don't you give it
to your new, fat, ugly girlfriend?
- I haven't even met her yet!
- Whatever!
- You left your jacket, Meegan!
- Oh, throw it in a river!
- Why would I (bleep) do that?
- I don't care, I'm over it!
- Fine!
(sighs) God.
Meegan!
- Leave me alone!
- Your jacket, though!
- No!
- Seriously, Meegan!
- You start buying drinks for everybody
as soon as she comes over.
I mean, who does that?
- Meegan, come back to the bar!
- You're literally an asshole!
- How is that possible?
I can't be an asshole, I got
arms and legs and a head!
- Where's my jacket?
- I have your jacket!
- Fine.
- Do you want it?
- No!
- You know wha-
- Eat it!
- Why would I do that?
You know what?
I'm not following you anymore!
- Fine! I'm over it!
- Fine!
Meegan, come back to the bar.
- No!
- Meegan! Meegan! Meegan!
- uh-uh! No! Uh-uh!
- Meegan, do you want your (bleep) jacket?
- No!
- Seriously, come back to the bar.
- You go back to the bar.
- I'm gonna throw this
jacket in the water.
- Oh, nice, that's really nice.
- What do you want me to do, Meegan? damn!
- Kiss my butthole, okay?
- Good, fine, fine!
Then I'm going, I'm leaving right now!
God damn it!
Meegan!
- No!
- Like, seriously, your jacket!
- But it's your jacket, though!
- Whatever!
- Meegan!
- No!
- I have your, I have your jacket.
- I'm over it!
- Seriously, meg-
(ominous music)
(moves into theme music)